That is a contradiction between economic
growth and the public space.
First of all,
I think the most crucial competitive
factor in
our time is he's not like the car,
the cruiser competitive factor in our
time.
It's not like he was in the past land or
even capital,
but people how to attract and retain the
best qualified people.
So I would say the most crucial
competitive issue in our time is quality
of life.
A public space is crucial for quality of
life.
Public pedestrian space,
Eh,
gives us quality.
It needs to retain great people at.
But also it's very important for the
people who live there themselves for the
poor.
I believe that there is no contradiction
whatsoever in trying to have investments
in great public pedestrian space,
but gratefully space,
however different from most things
governments do is not just a means.
Most things governments do are a means
to economic development.
Governments invents the roads in
tunnels,
in irrigation districts,
in ports,
in airports,
uh,
because it's necessarily for the country
to,
to produce material,
eh,
goods and services,
but,
but they are a means to an end.
The end.
What is the end?
The end is happiness in the case of
politic.
Pedestrian space is a very peculiar good
because it's an end in itself.
I mean it just to have great public
space makes people happier and creates
more social integration.
Again,
I believe it also creates economic
development because actually,
for example,
if I asked some people to go live in
some,
some cities in the third world have
serious problems like Lego's in Nigeria.
If people want to get
eh,
some,
a person to go live in lake or some,
uh,
some expert engineer in something,
they will have to pay him very,
very much to compensate for the
hardships of being in Legos if they had.
Instead,
when people go to Paris,
it happens.
The opposite.
People are willing to take a reduction
in their material will be in,
they go to a,
they may go without a car,
they go with a much smaller apartment
because the city gave them so much back.
So actually to invest in a good city is
good business is not robots and making
investment decisions.
And,
uh,
we need to make us eat that is
attractive to the people we most want to
have an sat
at adults who could actually go anywhere
in the world they want because they are
such good technicians or an artist or a
professionals or whatever they do that
they could choose to go wherever they
want.
And if we don't have a great city,
they will.